also area 15 that has become a go-to
spot for some much needed fun in town
and now
until january 3rd it's bringing us some
holiday cheer
with a twist rocky stopped by wanderland
to see it all for herself
[Music]
happy holidays from area 15. the
holidays
okay this is obviously holidays with a
twist tell us like this week well we're
on an art car
here this is uh area 15's version of
santa sleigh i love it got some alien
elves
all around the space lots of fun
instagramable moments for people to come
and have
holiday with a twist at area 15. holiday
with a choice but also safely as well
let's talk about how we can eat safely
well here's an example first of all we
have timed entry so it's not going to be
too crowded it's
outdoors but then on top of that you go
into your own little snow globe
how adorable is that so you're literally
inside a bubble having amazing food
so it couldn't be safer than that i
don't think and who's cooking over there
yeah that's todd english a celebrity
chef
and uh really good food awesome and of
course your small group groups are for
yeah exactly perfect so when you come
here you can take pictures on all of
these different
places here you see wonderland the photo
wander around there
you just go to area15.com you get your
tickets for 20 bucks timed entry
and then you're set to go wow okay so
just last question here
why is it so important to celebrate the
holidays especially this year for sure
man we've been through so much
and you can just imagine people kind of
getting the holidays and being all
exhausted but listen
we got to do it we're outdoors here
we're doing it safe let's have some
holiday cheer why not and i love it here
so i'm just telling you guys you'll have
so much fun at area 15 for the holidays
so come on down thank you